Hallo ihr Lieben!
Wir machen heute türkische Teigtaschen.
Pogaca nennt man die auf Türkisch und heute eine spezielle Variante:
wir machen nämlich Simit Pogaca! Simit kennt ihr vielleicht unter diesen runden Sesamkringeln.
Und es gibt auch Pogaca, also Simit Pogaca. Das sind dann einfach nur Teigtaschen,
die auch in diesem Sesam gewälzt werden und ach -
köstlich, einfach nur köstlich! Ich fange direkt an mit dem Teig,
ich habe jetzt hier Mehl in einer großen Schüssel.
(H: Und die Mengenangaben?)
Die Mengenangaben stehen immer unten
in der Videobeschreibung, die müsst ihr aufklappen und dann könnt ihr direkt einen Screenshot machen
und einkaufen gehen! Hier habe ich eine kleine Mulde drin, geb da jetzt lauwarmes Wasser dazu
und dann werde ich auch schon meine Hefe hineinbröseln lassen.
Ihr könntet hier auch alternativ Trockenhefe nehmen, ist auch kein Problem.
So, jetzt noch Zucker dazu und einmal grob verrühren.
So und nun zugedeckt 5min lang arbeiten lassen.
(H: Arbeite gut!)
Genau!
So, nach 5min einmal öffnen und Salz und Öl mit dazugeben
und dann knete ich das in der Küchenmaschine erst mal so ein paar Minuten
damit es sich überhaupt zu 'nem Teig verbindet und dann machen wir sowieso mit den Händen weiter.
Also ihr könnt auch den ganzen Teig mit den Händen kneten.
Das Besondere an diesem Teig ist: ihr braucht kein Ei und das ist schon sehr sehr geschmeidig,
also ich hab jetzt wirklich nur 2min oder so geknetet.
Deshalb ist das ganze Rezept auch vegan möglich falls Veganer unter uns sind,
dann müsst ihr einfach nur in der Füllung veganen Käse nehmen.
So und jetzt gebe ich den einmal in die Schüssel zurück, besprühe sie noch ein bisschen mit Backtrennspray,
das mache ich immer gerne wenn ich nicht möchte, dass noch mehr Mehl an den Teig kommt
damit er eben schön geschmeidig bleibt.
Ein bisschen nach oben drüber dass die Haut ein bisschen benetzt ist, einmal den Deckel drauf
und jetzt an einem warmen Ort 45min lang gehen lassen.
Für die leckere Füllung verrühren wir jetzt ganz einfach Schafskäse mit Goudakäse und Petersilie
und fertig ist unsere köstliche Füllung, die liebe ich total!
Ihr könnt auch die Kartoffel-Variante nehmen, die Hackfleisch-Variante...
Ich verlinke euch mal mein Standard Pogaca Rezept in die Infobox,
dann könnt ihr euch das auch gerne mal ansehen, ist aber ein sehr altes Video!
Und jetzt nehme ich mir den Teig - keine Panik, ich hab einen Schüsselwechsel
weil ich den Teig einfach vorbereitet hab - geb ihn mir auf die Arbeitsfläche
und dann unterteile ich ihn mit meiner Teigkarte.
So, jetzt habe ich 12 Kugeln geformt und ihr müsst die nicht noch mal gehen lassen,
wir legen direkt los mit der Füllung.
Ich hab jetzt hier eine Teigkugel und ich brauche noch nicht mal ein Nudelholz,
ich nehm' jetzt einfach die Hände und breite das oval aus.
Da kommt jetzt ein Esslöffel von der Käsefüllung rein und dann wird das einfach verschlossen.
So, jetzt kommt ein sehr spannender Teil. Das ist auch unerlässlich wenn ihr Simit Pogaca machen möchtet!
Wir brauchen Traubensirup und ich werde oft gefragt, ob man Traubensirup durch irgendwas ersetzen kann:
meiner Meinung nach nicht. Ich habe bei einer Zuschauerin gelesen die hat Dattelsirup genommen.
Die hat den bei uns im Shop bestellt und hat gedacht: "Ok, es gibt kein Traubensirup,
dann nehm ich Dattelsirup!"
Und sie meinte es hat ganz gut geklappt aber alle Angaben ohne Gewähr,
das ist jetzt nur eben ihr Erfahrungsbericht.
So und jetzt gebe ich hier zum Traubensirup noch ein bisschen Wasser, verrühre das
und in die andere Schale gebe ich Sesam. Der kann geröstet sein oder ungeröstet, das ist egal,
es kommt ja eh in den Backofen.
Und anschließend wird immer ein Pogaca in das Traubensirup-Gemisch gewälzt
dann in Sesam und dann direkt aufs Backblech.
So und dann schneide ich noch die Oberfläche an, ca 3 Mal, einfach der Optik wegen
und jetzt kann das Ganze auch schon in den Backofen wandern. Der ist vorgeheizt auf
180° C Ober- und Unterhitze. Und dann backen wir die Simit Pogacas im unteren Drittel für circa 25min,
das kann auch eine Minute weniger dauern.
Schaut, dass sie nicht zu dunkel werden, sie sollen schön goldbraun sein
und dann sind sie auch richtig schön fluffig!
Zu diesem Rezept kann ich nur sagen: wer die Simit Pogaca nicht ausprobiert, der ist selbst schuld!
Das klingt hart aber es ist wirklich so! ihr müsst es unbedingt ausprobieren
und mir euer Feedback hier unten in die Kommentare schreiben.
Und dann wünsche ich euch jetzt einfach nur noch viel Spaß beim Nachbacken,
viel Spaß beim Genießen, am besten lauwarm!
Mit Tee, Kaffee oder einfach zum Frühstück, passt einfach immer!
Und macht mich nicht verantwortlich wenn ihr süchtig werdet, das ist nämlich ganz normal bei diesem Rezept!
Ansonsten noch einen wunderschönen Tag und bis zum nächsten Mal auf Kikis Kitchen!
Tschüüss, vergesst das Abo nicht!